so angry Joe and I but sorry for the I'm
gonna kick your ass right now I remember
what just happened last time we played
together MKS and I'm ready to [ __ ]
kick your ass all right
you know what's funny what you said the
big slips a pig in fkx he said I'm about
to kick your [ __ ] ass I'll actually
show all this victory yeah we shall see
they ass will be kicked all right
anytime again with a brand new character
of no [ __ ] truth all right we got
balls beep oh God
no wait let me see it's called bone bone
deep I'm gonna call the balls deep
though lack of steep Jeremy I know you
think I should do balls [ __ ] ok let's
try it let's try it yeah balls deep
those sound pretty good
okay but not both deep sounds like it
feels pretty good I think this is gonna
be a pretty good match yeah it's gonna
be a long girthy man oh I was wondering
if we're controlling those are we not I
don't know I wanna I need to go back to
that that would be cool if there's like
a little mini game yeah while we kick
each other's ass before we kick each
other's yeah oh he's ready he does have
the metal cuz usually it's bone oh [ __ ]
he looks like a [ __ ] knobhead max no
Lord of the Rings what's up
he knows the collective there guys I was
gonna say Mad Max I got Sandman here oh
we got it we got a pup oh you already go
all right you ready yeah go
now I'm about to kick you oh come on
that sand trap Oh
oh god maybe right he's like Jack well
lucky doesn't have his salad move
where's this salad give me a salad I
want to see it I'm allowing you to give
me a salad he doesn't have a salad move
here's the like you're on the wrong
Barry yeah I am no you I think you found
your guy I think you found your guy he's
a judge apparently controlled time but I
can't get the temple advantage to go on
there it goes wait oh I'm frozen that
okay
I was like a net or something that's a
[ __ ] up move
[Applause]
oh you know what you know what it's Bubo
time we gonna go I was using the
mechanic cuz I heard him say the fatal
blow will come back and so really I
tried to wait two ferns to come back and
it did and then you just blocked it
twice
very well done oh oh yeah I could
continue to hit you that is so sick
[Applause]
no you don't know you saw let's see a
good one Phase II oh all right looking
through time anywhere back down down
eggs from anywhere yeah here we go let's
see if this cool new character boom
punch the hole in his chest
good that was really good I think you
found your guy you're good with that
dude okay I'm gonna rematch you rematch
with a good Baraka bill that I know
[Music]
lightning rod stormy Daniels we're gonna
do that all day yeah he's good red he's
rockin class I like that that's sharp we
can we can't hear it here all right we
gotta go to the move I'll give you a
blood ball just to see I'm gonna give me
one of these what's top wall that is
seriously cool that's like Raiden for
doing this God yeah
[Applause]
I like I like you I like you okay all
right all right it's gonna dagger yeah I
can bag it red move she liked us that
look like a nun getting knocked up all
right I see out it no you fastest you're
no joke though they're trying to get
hurt all right I got it I got a look at
another move I don't know why I just
after what is that what does it do
Oh oops
[Applause]
flying in the air I'm not so hot you
know what that was a good never lower
your eyes to is the phrase you look upon
us there we go
like a nun that's good oh that's very
low Tiant its Loki no there's no more
that cherry on top did not come today
all right I say we do another one that
was that was cheap of me I would I'm
sorry you know what that would like to
here's the good part it's only a game
target okay let's do this new Ronda
Rousey all right welcome scoping so
[ __ ] cool fine celebrity voice acting
but I'm not so sure about changing the
character model oh oh she's doing
military
she's got the armbar that's oh good job
yeah his his spear oh okay I am good
with Sonia
[Music]
that was awesome
now do you think that Jesse is still
here cuz I love Cassie yes she has to be
pushing three eyeballs he doesn't stop
I think Cassie should be there because I
love castor - Cassie's the back yeah
yeah that's a fatality okay you cheap
ass [ __ ] now I'm [ __ ] leg
breaker okay ash listen here we go oh
how you spider monkey
[Music]
how out yeah and we do it we're not
doing a lot of graphs that's good from
Mk
fin it dude oh that's far that's oh
oh that's really good
just as an end scene that's art that's
art that is art that's what I'm saying
about Mortal Kombat it's like to get
creative to get this kind of creativity
with death is a [ __ ] art form yeah
look at that end pose that's the cover
of the game right there dude
okay so I have to go best of five I'm to
your one and let's use new characters
alright wrap this up for the Super Bowl
I'm a head so you weren't good with
Raiden so I guess I'm I wasn't too great
with red I'm doing hack and slash yeah
you gotta get bro I gotta go salad yeah
salad flies are scared of that who did
we freeze oh no we don't bone my bone
claws will get us better than Wolverine
claws
alright okay damn it
damnit ah [ __ ] you put you up against
the wall
oh you said no
oh yeah this is counter flake
never underestimate the power of the
ground man what's that good for
skipper when you jump yeah Wow [ __ ] me
wait did you lay your staff down yeah
I'm trying to figure out how to trigger
now you're so lucky Charlie yeah this is
one of your mains I'm thinking out my
big butt face now it's our cotton not
everyone keeps their genitals in the
same place captain take it Raiden
standing there like he's awesome he is
[Music]
he got his board let's go all right
Oh fine it's example if you got me so
that's interesting I gotta figure out
when is that useful
oh wow
[ __ ] I won't lie you haven't got a
scared dude there's double chaos or
there has to be because yeah they let
blowing you it me home I need a breather
alright back to back to combat movie
that could be the variant cover are you
recording this [ __ ] okay good that's
good
alright so that's two - that's two - oh
[ __ ] okay anybody's game so the next one
is it right god I don't want to pick
anyone else I don't know I mean I was
good with him I'm gonna go for broke
somebody's up here alright I'm gonna do
scorpion I'm all about trying new things
okay it's time to thank those like
really go I love the fact that you can
change your costumes and I hope they put
some classic skins in
from time oh he looks different I
thought I thought Matt oh you cut during
their mad [ __ ] talk do your worst BFFs
okay yeah wait for it I could feel your
[ __ ] your combos here you even duster
to my club and then I stopped subscribe
sub-zero best in this bitterness
chairman he was the last one [ __ ]
care you should have gone with oh how
are you even that's not right that is
not right let me get a new character
damn out [ __ ] jump jump jump
Oh
oh sure I'm gonna freeze you before and
you said yeah I love that one that's one
of the best I've seen today
[Applause]
whoa very nice
oh that's a good reverse this is a good
match but it's not until I fell it's not
until I tell somebody all right one is
what stonecutter is that the execution
block guy yeah that's the exit this ice
cutter is eggs you know the block I
don't like the block too much all right
all right
I wish use this gold in the ball that
was a good game dude that was like that
was edge of the seat it was we did it
besides the fact that you're like I just
I just want to see this one thing good
but we did it this is angry Joe follow
I'll be great dude
you're always super fun it's great to
hang out with you I mean even off-camera
I love to shoot in this [ __ ] with you
and just talking about everything that
was badass
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see mark the chopping
block do my you knew you're another
heretic executed sass
all day doing that
[Music]